what I find really fascinating about
your philanthropy is that you give to
encourage other people also to give back
to Yale and we've talked in the series
with philanthropist who give to build
schools or to ferment like civil rights
movements but you're giving is different
in that special way so what are some
methods that you've used to try to have
people to give back to Yale and what are
some difficulties you've encountered in
that well let me parse it a little bit
because we one of the things that I
think about when I was first asked to
participate was this is a way I can give
back because at the time I didn't have a
lot of money but I can give my time and
talent to help that time it was a local
Yale Club so I think that in a way it's
easy for me to get people to it's easier
to give you ask people to give time and
talent than money I find it easier and
it's usually usually get a response so
what we'll do with the with Yale women
as an example or even the aya is to try
to get people involved as I was talking
about before was something that they're
passionate about say this is an
opportunity for you to a come back and
meet other the alleys to get engaged in
that way to get intellectual stimulation
when you come back to campus to revisit
your college experience I mean that's
sort of a hook that seems very selfish
but in the process you come involved in
an organization that actually leads to
some of the other things that you're
talking about and what you know things
that are happening in the Alumni world
through the support of the aya and I
hope will happen with Yale women are
building schools helping you know in
education and in the arts and you know
you name it that somebody's interested
in doing we we can help generate those
activities through bringing Ellie's
together I think the biggest challenge
is really getting the word out about it
is making people understand there's a
there's some famous stories about I will
go into the details but when alums get
communication from Yale most of them
assume they're being asked for money and
we don't ask for my we asked for time
and talent we asked for ideas I think
the hardest challenge is to get the
no world to understand that that's what
we're there for is to create
relationships and to help connect them
back to the University right so on the
topic of creating these relationships
what are some examples of successful
programming that helped to maintain
these communities outside appeal for
people who may have been in different
class years they've never met before how
does that factor into maintaining and
gluing these communities together well
the one that comes to mind quickest is
the Yale Service Corps one of our
initiatives in the last five years was
to have this yell Service Corps which
now has its own sort of sub board of the
aya who started out with a project going
to the Dominican Republic over spring
break four years ago maybe to partner
with an organization down there to work
in in in the community and what's
fascinating about that is there was an
email sent out from Yale to ask people
to go on the trip it had the word
service in the subject line and I cannot
tell you how many people I think about a
hundred people wanted the trip but a
huge percentage of them had never done
anything in connection with UL before
and some of these were people who
graduated in the 60s and they work they
said they only opened the email because
they saw the word service and they
thought it was such a great idea to go
with other Yale ease and some of them
some of them took families the Dominican
Republic to do with a service project
that they joined up and they have since
a lot of them have since become very
very involved and we've had many many
trips since then but I think again it's
broadening the way you think about how
alumni interact with each other and the
world there are a lot of universities oh
don't get this they say well why would I
want to partner with Habitat for
Humanity and bring my XYZ College alums
to do that what do I get out of it and
our question is not what do I get out of
it it's it's um what can i bring to it
and and it's a hard question I mean is
there such a thing as altruism you know
it you know i get i get a lot out of
this i almost feel guilty because I I do
this because I enjoy it so much and I
get to meet fabulous people like maximan
and interact with students but I think
there's something something beyond that
that just but you
try to weave appeal to that and brought
into the aya fold actively people who
didn't have time for it before didn't
think they care